[Music]
dr jack bright's life has been largely
defined by one really bad day namely
back when he was a mere junior
researcher from an illustrious
complicated and foundation-connected
family he was given the task of carrying
the
scp-963 medallion all the way from the
test chamber back to its containment
area simple enough seeing as other than
being indestructible the medallion had
no obvious anomalous effects that was
until able breached containment nearby
and hacked the young jack bright to
death with his anomalous blades but in
what you could either describe as a
miracle or a terrible terrible curse dr
bright wasn't dead his soul was trapped
in the medallion taking over any body it
touched this has given dr bryant a form
of body swapping immortality which has
made him both a valuable asset to the
goals of the scp foundation and also an
extremely unhappy man but what would you
do if you were immortal like jack bright
we posed this very question in our
community post section and now we're
going to see what the fans of scp
explained would do with the poison gift
of true immortality the unknown avenger
said i would become a vigilante who
doesn't have to worry about facing
justice through the death sentence if i
get executed i'll simply reincarnate as
someone new and continue my vigilante
justice work well that's somewhat
terrifying thank you for sharing unknown
avenger all we ask is that you politely
keep your dangerous vigilante activities
away from us just so we don't get caught
in the crossfire we're really not sure
the universe can take two deadpools
vance alexander said
bearing in mind the duplicating ability
of the medallion i'd make two of myself
and then fight myself or i wouldn't
limit it to two i'd make a whole bunch
of copies and have a battle royale of
myself may the best copy win this gives
us an important opportunity to remind
you of one of dr bright's lesser known
abilities contact with a necklace means
immediate brain death and if the
necklace is removed from the wearer the
body will simply collapse and die
however the necklace is left on the body
for 30 days a copy of dr bright's
consciousness will remain even when the
necklace is removed theoretically this
could be used to create a clone army and
using that army for self-against
self-gladiator battles would undeniably
be pretty kick ass
deadly veggie said if i was immortal i
would try to play and complete the
stories of every d d character i've made
now that would be something only an
immortal could do a truly avant-garde
approach using one infinite life to live
the countless finite lives of others
knowing that not even a nat 20 will save
you from your own purgatorial existence
phantom said that's actually a really
tough one i'm unironically scared to
death of dying so i guess i just try to
do things i want to do probably would
end up trying to become a well-known
gamer or something bull or maybe teach
forever it's depressing since it's such
a curse to be immortal while we do think
being a teacher or a well-known gamer
are both noble pursuits for the immortal
about town we're honestly more curious
as to what being ironically scared of
dying would be is that what the kids are
into nowadays let us know down in the
comments mr knight the detective said i
would have time to watch pretty much
every cartoon anime movie and series i
ever missed after i'm done with all of
them i will fulfill my bucket list with
other wishes this is certainly a novel
way to use total immortality but a word
to the wise make sure you get through
your watch list before the rest of
humanity is wiped out by whatever xk
class end of the world scenario lady
luck has lined up for us our money is
either on climate change or the
duplicating cakes because if you're the
only one left and you happen to break
your glasses you'll forever be wandering
around the empty waists tearfully
murmuring it isn't fair there was time
now there was time what is a melon said
personally i would try and make a time
machine to watch many historical events
unfold i mean you have plenty of time
and you can't die from any certain event
could be fun a lofty goal indeed here's
a fun exercise for you to immediately
find out if you're ever going to create
or at least obtain time travel
technology in your lifetime make a
promise to yourself that if you do
you'll come back to this exact moment
okay
good however if a version of you from
the future hasn't just appeared in front
of you then i'm afraid i have some very
disappointing news for you on the whole
time travel thing kate peterson said i'm
kind of confused with how the amulet
works if dr bright died and then
somebody put the amulet on an animal
would he become the animal and still be
able to talk or would the animal just
turn into him next question with that in
mind couldn't he just get it to be put
on an anomalous object such as 682 and
use it for good all very valid questions
that is worth answering before we move
on first if dr bright's 963 amulet was
placed on the body of an animal it would
merely plant his consciousness into the
animal not in any way physically
transform the beast whether the animal
could talk purely depends on whether it
has the necessary anatomy to imitate
human-esque speech patterns and as to
your second question this has been
attempted with scp-682 specifically in
fact see our previous video on how that
epic battle played out but to give you
an abridged version some anomalous
entities are more resistant to scp-960
abilities than us mere humans are not
all potential hosts are created equal
foxy gamer said i drink one drop of
water from every country and one drop of
lava from every volcano then probably
watch as every generation of humanity
expand and rule it this is the exact
kind of bizarre inexplicable madness we
were hoping to see when we first posed
this question the specificity of these
suggestions implies a fascinating level
of planning and foresight and it's
undeniable that if you were able to
prove to people you had imbibed a drop
of lava from every single volcano on
earth there's about 1 350 active ones by
the way you probably would have some
claim to being humanity's supreme ruler
or just someone who's very spicy
mangalad said if i had the power like
bright i would create the ultimate wine
make it rest on a barrel as long as
possible ah yes i see we have a person
of culture among us
can't wait for all the comments to be
about me saying among us god nonetheless
having dr bright's immortality would be
an excellent excuse to cultivate some of
the finest aged wine the world has ever
known perhaps those sweet overtones and
nutty undertones will dull the
existential horror of never knowing the
eternal rest of death and i swear to god
the comments are just going to say
amogus quote c said oh boy immortality
now i can dedicate more time to my
favorite hobby procrastinating on
animation projects that's the can-do
attitude we love here at scp explained
eternity certainly lasts a while imagine
all the incredible animations you could
not get done in that time
inspirational
the outsider said dedicating yourself to
something meaningful like jack bright is
the only way to do it that is of course
after you had some fun for the first few
decades we couldn't agree more outsider
after all you only live once still
applies even if that once lasts forever
dr bright tried to have some fun on his
own before he leveled out and now
there's a very long list of things he's
not allowed to do perhaps we should
cover that someday michael awesome said
if i were immortal i would steer
humanity into the direction of logic and
science guiding them from the shadows
into an eternal golden age using the
resources i've accumulated through
forever that certainly sounds awesome
michael however feel free to call us
pessimists but humanity has never been
that easy to steer out of the shadows
see the long list of very smart
paradigm-shifting individuals executed
as witches or heretics for such bold and
radical claims as the earth rotates
around the sun and math exists but we'll
be happy to be proven wrong on this
front of course silent monkey said
dedicate my life into turning into a hot
dog sandwich hey if you can find a very
unscrupulous man with a meat mincing
machine you may take a lot less time
than eternity to see this peculiar dream
become a glorious reality no x69
nice said i would make an army of myself
and when i wouldn't want to go to the
store then i would just send my clone
for some doritos there are a lot of
truly nefarious and megalomaniacal
things you can do with an army of
like-minded clones like the battle
royale guy from earlier so it's
relieving that you just use yours for
performing menial tasks but bear in mind
just because these clones are
like-minded doesn't mean they'll be
subservient to you if you're the
controlling type you might even have a
violent clone uprising on your hands and
trust us nobody likes an attack of the
clones food for thought the voices
gaming said depending on how the
medallion works i try to keep me and the
woman i love alive if i can't do that
then i'd give up the medallion to the
scp foundation assuming it exists a life
without someone is in a life worth
living no matter how much you've
accomplished it'll always get boring
eventually a very poignant point we have
good news and bad news technically
speaking with the help of your 963
medallion your loved one's body can
survive however their brain will
technically be occupied by a copy of
your own consciousness but if that copy
is willing to play pretend well maybe
you can make some kind of mutually
beneficial arrangement the finer details
of that will be something for you and
yourself to sort out good luck fox films
said i would freak someone out by
repeatedly over the course of a few
years going up to them in different
bodies and saying the same phrase each
time using your abilities to gaslight
one individual over the course of
several years definitely seems like
something dr bright might do if he was
in a bad mood so we're sure he would
appreciate this act of extreme anomalous
pettiness just promise you won't do it
to us this really isn't something we
want on our plate right now zero
confidence said well a good portion of
my lives would be developing a
meaningful relationship with 682 via the
process of annoying them with my
presence every few weeks or when i'm
tired of my current body and ready to
move on to that nice d-class who was
next in line this is definitely an
original one we appreciate that you're
still rosyied about the possibility of a
single atom of goodness residing
somewhere deep beneath
scp-682's nasty scaly hide whether
you'll actually find it even with an
eternity of searching is another
question but if goodwill hunting has
taught us anything if you repeat it's
not your fault enough even if it kills
you a thousand times in between it might
eventually have a cathartic emotional
outpouring hey it's worth a try right
cracker county said i'd enact minuscule
amounts of tomfoolery at the expense of
others hey you know what you like and
you're doing what you can to obtain it
we can't help but respect that about you
sometimes setting modest yet attainable
goals is the most efficient way to go
even when you have an eternity at your
fingertips nicholas lau said personally
i go to space with a lot of pain
medication and magnetic boots then do
laps around the asteroid belt if i'm
immortal even with all that pain i could
do a proper jog that isn't just
strolling around the block also figure
out a cure for cancer and whipping
scp-038 with really long spaghetti for
infinite food wow
this is a hell of a bucket list even for
someone who knows they're never actually
going to kick that bucket we don't want
to mess with your dreams here but it is
important to remember that there is
considerable distance between asteroids
in an asteroid belt even in a low
gravity environment so you may need to
seriously work on your jumping skills
the cure for cancer is an undeniably
notable goal and we're personally very
invested in you using scp-038
a tree that clones anything that touches
it to create infinite spaghetti we find
that idea to be
mine scarfed bro said if i was immortal
i would probably go to the cell shy guy
and look at him that is certainly an
interesting way to spend your time but
there are two worrying potential issues
that could come up here famously scp-096
leaves no trace of its victims so it'd
be fascinating to see if the scp-963
medallion would be left after the
onslaught however we find our second
concern to be an even more frightening
possibility what if the rage state of
scp-096 carried over between bodies what
if every time you regenerated
scp-096 was activated anew and made a
b-line for you you would be in the worst
kind of hell caught in an infinite loop
of being murdered by
scp-096 again and again until the world
collapses between the two of you so yes
we personally think that this little
stunt just may not be worth the risk
defordial said i would probably spend my
time learning all languages science and
basically everything i guess and then
try to ascend high in the ranks of the
foundation and someday become a member
of the o5 council unlikely though since
the o5 could be immortal as well and
maybe accumulate more power by throwing
my medallion at anomalies funnily enough
this is pretty much exactly how jack
bright himself uses the medallion so
you'd probably be in good company with
the scp foundation's grumpiest immortal
pandy goodies said i'd probably do
whatever i can to ensure every meme and
joke thrown at the internet revivable
i'll bring back catburger's means in the
year 3022 of all the suggestions we've
observed today this is undeniably the
evilest of them all pandy goodies and we
swear that if you use this power to give
immortality to the among us memes that
plague our comment sections you will
have a powerful enemy in scp explained
today you have our word on that
seriously samantha aegis said to be
honest i feel sorry for dr jack bright
and his family everyone deserves a fresh
start right we're with you on this one
samantha the ballad of jack bright
himself and the terrible tragedies and
upsets that pervade his family easily
tugs at the heartstrings if today has
taught us anything it's that there truly
is no longevity without tragedy horseman
gaming said if i was immortal i'd spend
my time finding ways to become as smart
as rick sanchez invent the
interdimensional portal gun and start
dimension hopping or more accurately
pitching my medallion into the portal
seeing where it goes after all it is
indestructible using the scp-963
medallion to become rick sanchez is
certainly a new one perhaps then you can
place the medallion onto a pickle and
then it'd be the funniest wait what do
you mean it's a dead meme well it
doesn't matter because if panty goodies
gets their way no meme will ever really
die no matter how obnoxious and i know
i'm a mean boy prosimity said i would
plant as many trees in the world as i
can and watch them grow well that's just
incredibly wholesome and we think that
this would be a truly wonderful way to
use the power of immortality a shiny scp
foundation gold star for you prosimity
uaf gammon said i'd probably actually
start working on my mental health hey
for what it's worth don't wait for the
gift of immortality to be bestowed on
you before you start working on your
mental health working on yourself is
always a good thing and if you've been
looking for an excuse there's no better
time to start than right now liara saluk
said after sulking over how everyone i
know and will know is either dead or
will die during my never ending lifespan
i would learn everything i could about
any topic simply because i had the time
to whether it would be about the weather
or about anomalies and the foundation i
would set to working my way into the
foundation and getting a good acceptable
job that gave me enough clearance to be
able to access the most information
possible i would then work in two ways
one by helping with the actual goals of
the foundation and all that comes with
that and also by working my passion
writing stories and implementing many
things i would see working at such a
place as the scp foundation different
enough that it wasn't an exact copy but
similar enough so that if someone were
to read it after having heard rumors
about such a beast they would assume it
came from the book and it was in fact
fiction and not reality an extra defense
against people finding out the truth dr
bright is that you
what do we tell you about making sock
puppet accounts and commenting on our
community posts the o5 council is going
to give you a very stern talking to
about this johanni plays said i'd play
every video game out there and i'd watch
every scp explained story in animation
video we think this is a truly excellent
idea and something we should all do
right now even if we're not immortal
heck perhaps you should start with scp
immortal dr bright explained and dr
bright for president
scp-4444 bush vs gore a great pair of
videos if you're interested in more
exploits from the truly legendary dr
jack bright what we're just saying